SO, WHAT WENT ON BEHIND THE
SCENES TO GET TO THIS POINT?
LET'S BRING IN THE U.S.
AMBASSADOR TO RUSSIA, AMBASSADOR
JOHN SULLIVAN.
MR. AMBASSADOR, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND FOR BEING
HERE.
JUST WALK US THROUGH THE
NEGOTIATIONS AND WHAT IT TOOK TO
GET TREVOR REED BACK HOME.
>> WELL, THANKS, ALYSON.
IT'S GREAT TO BE WITH YOU TODAY.
YEAH, IT'S A JOYOUS DAY FOR THE
REED FAMILY, THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT, FOR ME, AND ALL
AMERICANS.
TREVOR WAS FREED.
HE WAS QUICKED YEARS AGO OF A
CRIME HE DIDN'T COMMIT.
AS YOU KNOW, HE HAS BEEN
RELEASED.
THIS IS A MATTER THAT WE HAVE
BEEN IN DISCUSSION, HIS CASE,
ALONG WITH OTHER AMERICANS WHO
HAVE BEEN DETAINED HERE.
PRINCIPALLY KWHAOE HAND AND NOW
OTHERS WHO HAVE BEEN DETAINED
RECENTLY.
I HAVE BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT FOR
YEARS OVER THOSE CASES.
THE TALKS HAVE EBBED AND FLOWED
OVER TIME AS THE INTEREST IN THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT AND PURSUING
A RELEASE FOR THESE AMERICANS
HAS GONE UP AND DOWN.
SO IN RECENT WEEKS IN
PARTICULAR, BECAUSE OF A
DETERIORATION WE SAW IN TREVOR'S
HEALTH, WE HAVE BEEN ENGAGED
WITH THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT ON
HIS RELEASE.
SO THOSE DISCUSSIONS ULTIMATELY
CULMINATED, AS YOU NOTED IN THE
DECISION BY PRESIDENT BIDEN TO
COMMUTE THE SENTENCE OF A
RUSSIAN CRIMINAL WHO HAD BEEN IN
U.S. PRISONS FOR A VERY LONG
PERIOD OF TIME SERVING A
NARCOTICS SENTENCE.
AND THAT TRADE WAS EXECUTED ON
WEDNESDAY.
.
>> YOU BROUGHT UP THE OTHER
AMERICANS, BRITTANY GRINER IS
OBVIOUSLY STILL THERE.
AND PAUL WHELAN.
CNN OBTAINED A STATEMENT THAT
PAUL WHELAN GAVE YESTERDAY.
HE SAID WHY WAS I LEFT BEHIND?
WHILE I AM PLEASED TREVOR IS
HOME WITH HIS FAMILY, I HAVE
BEEN HELD ON A FICTITIOUS CHARGE
OF ESPIONAGE FOR 40 MONTHS.
THE WORLD KNOWS THIS CHARGE WAS
FABRICATED.
WHY HASN'T MORE BEEN DONE FOR MY
RELEASE.
.
>> I HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
HIS RELEASE PUBLICLY AND IN
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT SINCE BEFORE I GOT
HERE AS AMBASSADOR.
WHEN I WAS DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
STATE.
WHEN PAUL WAS ORIGINALLY
ARRESTED BACK IN DECEMBER OF
2018.
I'VE SAID THAT SINCE I ARRIVED
HERE AS AMBASSADOR IN JANUARY OF
2020 WE HAVE NO HIGHER PRIORITY,
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS NO
HIGHER PRIORITY, THAN THE
RELEASE OF ALL AMERICANS WHO ARE
WRONGFULLY DETAINED HERE.
THIS IS JUST ONE STEP, ALYSON,
THIS CASE, TREVOR'S CASE IS JUST
ONE STEP.
I'VE NEVER RELENTED IN MY
ADVOCACY FOR PAUL IN AN
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT FOR PAUL'S RELEASE.
AND MY HOPE AND EXPECTATION IS
THAT WE WILL ULTIMATELY SEE THAT
LEAD TO SUCCESS WITH PAUL'S
RELEASE.
HE SHOULD BE HOME IN MICHIGAN
WITH HIS FAMILY, WITH HIS
ELDERLY PARENTS.
AND I HAVE NO HIGHER PRIORITY.
THERE ARE ANY NUMBER OF
AMERICANS HERE.
YOU MENTIONED ONE QUITE
PROMINENT AMERICAN, WONDERFUL
AMERICAN, HUGELY TALENTED,
TWO-TIME OLYMPIC GOLD MEDALIST
BRITTANY GRINER, ARRESTED TWO
MONTHS AGO.
AND OTHERS WHO ARE NOT AS
WELL-KNOWN AS BRITTANY.
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF THEM IS OF
GREAT CONCERN TO ME.
I'M HAPPY TODAY THAT TREVOR IS
RELEASED.
BUT I'M FOCUSED EVEN MORE SO ON
WORKING ON PAUL'S RELEASE,
BRITTANY'S CASE AND THE OTHER
AMERICANS.
.
>> MR. AMBASSADOR, I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE DESCRIBED U.S./RUSSIAN
RELATIONS AS BAD, QUOTE, AS BAD
AS THEY'VE EVER BEEN.
IS THIS BECAUSE OF THE WAR IN
UKRAINE OR SOMETHING THAT
PREDATES IT?
.
>> IT HAS DRIVEN INTO THE
DEPTHS.
I HAVE PREVIOUSLY IN INTERVIEWS
REFERRED TO THE DEEPEST POINT IN
THE OCEAN IN THE PACIFIC,
MARIANA.
WE ARE AT A LOW.
I'M NOT SURE IT'S THE DEEPEST
EVER IN U.S./SOVIET RELATIONS.
YOU KNOW, THE CUBAN MISSILE
CRISIS COMES TO MIND.
BUT IT'S ABOUT AS BAD AS IT
COULD BE.
IT WAS BAD TO BEGIN WITH.
U.S./RUSSIAN RELATIONS WERE BAD
WHEN I ARRIVED HERE IN JANUARY
OF 2020.
THEY HAVE JUST GOTTEN WORSE,
SPIRALED DOWN WORD SINCE THEN.
AND NOW THEY HAVE REACHED A
POINT WHERE WE HAVE VERY LITTLE
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT.
I SPEAK TO THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT ABOUT OUR DETAINED
AMERICANS HERE, THOSE UNJUSTLY
DETAINED, PAUL WHELAN, BRITTANY
GRINER, THE OTHERS.
AND THE FUNCTIONING OF OUR
EMBASSY, KEEPING IT OPEN SO I
CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS.
BUT THERE IS VERY LITTLE ELSE.
IT IS NOT BUSINESS AS USUAL.
AND BUSINESS AS USUAL BEFORE
FEBRUARY 24th WAS VERY LITTLE
BUSINESS TO BEGIN WITH.
.
>> THE U.N. SECRETARY-GENERAL
JUST TOLD ANDERSON COOPER, THIS
WAR WILL NOT END WITH MEETINGS.
IT WILL END WHEN RUSSIA DECIDES
TO END IT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WILL GET
VLADIMIR PUTIN TO END THIS WAR?
>> Reporter: WELL, FIRST, I
COULDN'T AGREE MORE WITH THE
SECRETARY-GENERAL MORE.
THIS WAR STARTED WITH A DECISION
BY PRESIDENT PUTIN.
IT WILL END WITH A DECISION BY
PRESIDENT PUTIN.
THIS IS A WAR OF CHOICE BY ONE
MAN, BY ONE GOVERNMENT, AN
AGGRESSIVE WAR OF CHOICE WHERE
WE HAVE SEEN HORRIFIC ATROCITIES
COMMITTED ON A SOVEREIGN COUNTRY
LED BY A DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED
GOVERNMENT.
AND THE STRATEGY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION PURSUED WITH OUR
ALLIES AND PARTNERS IS, FIRST,
TO PROVIDE ENORMOUS SUPPORT IN
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE,
DEVELOPMENT ASSISTANCE, DIRECT
FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S FIRST.
SECOND, TO IMPOSE ENORMOUS
COSTS, EXTRAORDINARY COSTS,
FINANCIAL SANCTIONS, EXPORT
CONTROLS, AIRSPACE CLOSURES,
PORT CLOSURES ON THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT.
FINALLY, BOLSTERING THE SECURITY
OF NATO, REAFFIRMING,
RECOMMITTING EACH AND EVERY NATO
MEMBER TO OUR COMMITMENTS TO
EACH OTHER IN STRENGTHENING THE
EASTERN FLANK OF NATO.
BUT ULTIMATELY I AGREE WITH THE
SECRETARY-GENERAL.
THIS WILL ULTIMATELY BE,
ULTIMATELY HAVE TO BE A DECISION
BY PRESIDENT PUTIN.
WE'RE GOING TO DO ALL WE CAN TO
MAKE SURE THAT DECISION IS A
STRATEGIC DEFEAT FOR HIM AND HIS
GOVERNMENT AND NOT A VICTIM FOR
HIM IN UKRAINE.
>>> AS YOU KNOW, THERE IS A
"SPECTRE" OF NUCLEAR WAR THAT
HANGS ALL OVER THIS.
THE RUSSIANS KEEP BRINGING IT UP
AND NOT TOTALLY PUTTING IT OFF
THE TABLE.
ARE THERE DIPLOMATIC EFFORTS TO
KEEP THE RUSSIANS FROM
CONSIDERING THAT OPTION?
>> WELL, ALYSON, I COULDN'T
AGREE WITH YOU MORE.
THIS RHETORICRHETORIC, WHICH WE
SEEN ESCALATE IN A DRAMATICALLY
IRRESPONSIBLE WAY RECENTLY,
ISN'T NEW.
THE SENIOR RUSSIAN LEADERS HAVE
BROUGHT UP TO ME IN DISCUSSIONS
I'VE HAD WITH THEM ABOUT
UKRAINE, SECURITY IN EUROPE, A
CONVERSATION THAT HAS BEGUN AS A
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT IN THE
PAST WERE ISSUES RELATED TO
UKRAINE, FOR EXAMPLE, YOU MAY
RECALL THE MINSK AGREEMENTS,
TRYING TO FIND A PATH FORWARD
FOR A POLITICAL SOLUTION IN
UKRAINE.
THAT CONVERSATION WOULD SPIRAL
WITH THE INTRODUCTION BY THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT OF STATEMENTS
SAYING THAT IF THE UNITED
STATES, NATO CONTINUED TO
SUPPORT THE GENOCIDAL NAZIS IN
UKRAINE, IT COULD LEAD TO
NUCLEAR CONFRONTATION,
REFERENCING THE CUBAN MISSILE
CRISIS.
MY REACTION ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE TABLE IS ASTONISHMENT.
WE HAVE GONE FROM 0 TO 60 ON THE
MINSK AGREEMENTS TO NUCLEAR WAR.
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
AT THE MOST SENIOR LEVELS OF THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT, AN ESCALATION
OF THAT RHETORIC.
WHAT HAVE WE DONE IN RESPONSE?
WE HAVE DONE THE RESPONSIBLE
THING.
THE PRESIDENT, SECRETARY AUSTIN
PAUSED AND CANCELED A MISSILE
TEST THAT WE HAD SCHEDULED, THAT
WE HAD NOTIFIED THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT LONG IN ADVANTAGE OF.
WE DO NOT PLAY NUCLEAR
BLINKSMANSHIP IN THIS CONTEXT.
WE COMMUNICATED THAT TO THE
RUSSIANS.
WE HEARD THEIR RHETORIC.
WE ARE PREPARED TO DETER NUCLEAR
AGGRESSION AGAINST THE UNITED
STATES AS WE HAVE BEEN FOR
DECADES BACK INTO TIME WITH